- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is add 48,029 to 233,930.
And like always, pause this
video, and I really encourage
you to try to figure it out on your own,
and let's see if we get the same answer.
And if we don't, why?
Alright, so the way I'm
going to tackle this,
I assume that you've had a go at it,
I'm going to take the larger number.
I'm going to write it on top.
I'm really doing the standard method.
There's multiple ways where you
can add multi-digit numbers,
but what I'm going to do is
really the most typical method.
And then I'm going to write
the smaller number below it,
but I'm going to match up the place value.
So I'm going to write the ones place
in the same column as the
ones place on the top number.
So this is the 10,000s place, so 48,029.
So nine ones is zero ones,
two tens, three tens,
so on and so forth.
And now I am ready to add.
So let's start in the ones place.
And if I'm adding numbers,
it's always a good idea to
start in the ones place.
Zero ones plus nine ones is nine ones.
Then I can go into the tens place.
Three tens plus two tens is five tens.
This is going well, alright.
Then I go to the hundreds place.
Nine hundreds plus zero hundreds,
well, that's just going
to be nine hundreds.
So far, so good.
Alright, now something
interesting is going to happen
in the thousands place.
Three thousands plus eight thousands,
well, that would be 11 thousands.
But we can rewrite 11
thousands as 1000 and one 10000
sometimes you might see this
described as carrying the one.
Three plus eight is 11
where you carry the one.
But all you're really doing is regrouping.
3000 plus 8000 is 11000, we
write the 1000 here and we
write the 10000 right over
there, the 10000 place.
And now so we have one 10000
plus three 10000s plus four
10000s so one plus three
plus four that's eight 10000s
or 80000.
And then last but not least
we have these two hundred
thousands right over there and we're done.
281,959 did you get the same answer?